Unknown: Okay,
Vivek Bald: well welcome
everyone, it's so wonderful to
see all of your faces, this is
one of those times that I really
love zoom, when I get to see
that our whole community
together on one screen. So as,
as most of you here know that
our program is a fairly intense
two years. And this is always
one of the, you know, if not the
highlight of every year is to
see all of the members of a
cohort present the work that's
come to fruition over the course
of these two years, two years is
a you know, a lot can happen in
two years as we know. But also
two years can go can go by very,
very quickly. And we ask a lot
of our students in that period
of time, our students come in
with an idea or two or three or
more. And then very quickly, we
we asked them to focus in on a
thesis topic and and then do the
research and then do the
writing. And, you know, that
happens in a real clip. And I'm
especially happy to be here for
this cohort, because last year
was the first time that I taught
the second semester course in
which students are asked to
first formulate a thesis
proposal. And so it's really
exciting to to be able to see
where things have have come to
from that point, that early
point in this process. The way
that we're going to do this
today is that we will I think
most of you probably have the
schedule, we're going to have
three presentations in the
morning session, then we'll have
a break. And for more
presentations in the afternoon.
For each student that's
presenting, and I'm going to
call on their, their thesis
advisor to do a short intro and
and then I'll just try to keep
things going. as we as we move
along. So the our first student
up this morning is Roya
Moussapour. And I would like to
ask Justin to
Unknown: get us started.
Justin Reich: Welcome, everyone
really wonderful to be here. Can
everybody hear me? Yep, yep.
Terrific. Yeah, Ray has been
just such a crucial and fabulous
part of our team for the past
two years. And we're incredibly
grateful for all of our
contributions. I know that there
are lots of folks from the
teaching systems lab here today
who are really excited to hear
more about her thesis, which is
born, you know, starts from a
personal experience that kind of
got underneath Roy's skin. And
she really demonstrates in a
powerful way, what some
intensive research to try to
understand things in the media
ecosystem
that feel problematic to us can
look like after deep study. So
really proud of his work and
excited to hear it in its newest
form.
Vivek Bald: So I'm going to pass
it to Roya. The title of Roya's
thesis is cashing in on student
data, standardized testing and
predatory college marketing in
the United States. All right,
Roya Moussapour: thank you.
I'm just gonna take one second.
I'm apologize. First off,
because I have a couple of
screens here. So if you see me
look over to one of them. Don't
be alarmed.
Coming up, okay. Great. Well,
good morning, everyone. Thank
you to Vivek and Shannon and
Justin for the intro and for
setting this all up. I think
it's been it's been a wild year
to be doing all of this
research. And I think I speak
for all of my classmates and
saying thanks for supporting us
through all of this while we've
been scattered across the
country. And so today, I want to
introduce you to some core
aspects of my thesis research.
So I'll set this up with a bit
of a personal story to tell you
why I'm motivated to study the
standardized testing and
predatory marketing that happens
around the college admissions
process. So 10 or so years ago,
I was a high school junior
starting my college process. And
as the oldest of three, I was
the first to go through the
process. And I had really quite
excellent access to college
counseling at my high school.
But I felt like I had a lot to
learn. And I know that my
parents are on right now. And
I'm sure that they would
probably agree with that. So
when I took the SAT, for the
first time, I realized I was
eligible to sign up for
something called the student
search service, which is a
college board service that
provides students with
personalized college
recommendations, and all kinds
of outreach from universities.
So I really eagerly signed up. I
was excited to get mailers and
emails from universities that
thought I should apply. So I
want to kind of take you back in
time and show you what that
looked like on one of the first
days I started receiving emails
from universities. So here's my
inbox as a high school junior, I
would say it's pretty typical.
I've emails from concert venues,
17 magazine, Groupon, but what
really strikes me here is the
number of universities that that
had emailed me on this day. So
not long after I started
receiving these emails, I
actually revoked my consent from
the program. I found the emails
overwhelmingly annoying, and
really so generic that they
provided me with very little
information that was actually
aiding my college search. But I
continued to receive emails, and
I even reached out to the
College Board to try to figure
out why. And they actually
confirmed that I was not
subscribed to any email
newsletters at all. Later on
that year, they emailed me three
separate times to ask if I
wanted to rejoin the student
search service, which to me was
proof that I wasn't actively
signed up, even though I
continued to receive emails. And
I ended up actually receiving
emails for nearly a year after
revoking my permission from
participation. So 10 years
later, I found myself really
puzzled by that fact. Why did I
continue receiving emails after
revoking my consent? Where was
my personal information in this
process as a high school or
minor? And how is it being used?
So after all of this time, a lot
more school and much, much more
reading. I think I finally have
the right words to describe what
this was. So in my thesis, I
argue that programs like the
College Board student search
service facilitate something
called surveillance capitalism,
which is a phrase coined by a
Harvard researcher and Professor
Shoshana Zuboff. I'll explain a
little bit more about
surveillance capitalism a couple
minutes. But at the most basic
level surveillance capitalism is
the idea that your personal
information traits and behavior
can be rendered into data
feeding into predictive products
that help large companies
provide things like targeted
advertising, and then ultimately
allows those companies to make
predictions about your future
behavior and even shape your
future behavior. So I argue in
my thesis, that while we need
more transparency around these
practices, our ultimate need is
greater regulation of companies
and organizations. So I see my
contribution to academic
discourse around surveillance
capitalism. And more broadly,
what I'm referring to here is
critical data studies. I see
this as a key example of
surveillance capitalism that I
hope to convince you, in the
course of this talk, at least,
is entirely unethical, and the
potential implications for such
practice practices. So very
briefly, just a quick overview
of kind of where I'll take you
in the next half an hour. So I'm
going to take a moment to just
situate this thesis within the
sort of broader academic
discourse. And then I'll
introduce you to the privacy
framework that I build, through
my thesis to rely upon to
analyze the actions of the
College Board, very briefly
touch on methodology, and then
really dive into two key case
studies involving the student
search service, and then talk
about how those kind of
translate into predatory
marketing and the ethical
implications for data collection
and analysis in this process.
Finally, I'll talk about sort of
where do we go from here? What
are the takeaways?
So I see this thesis and this is
this is sort of a question I go
back. Back to pretty often
within Media Studies, at least I
see this thesis sitting at the
intersection of what I'm calling
education, critical data
studies, and law and public
policy. So I draw from each
field in order to understand the
implications for programs like
the College Board, students
search service, in the broader
discourse around data
collection, algorithmic decision
making, and predatory marketing.
So these are some examples of
who I've been reading for the
last couple of years. And I want
to bring these up as individuals
thinking critically about data
studies in various spaces. So on
the right, you see Justin's
book, Failure to Disrupt, within
education. We have people
thinking about this within
financial institutions on social
media, and in many cases, the
implications for what all of
these individuals are studying
tend to impact people of color
and people impacted by poverty
most directly. So I'll take a
second you see on the left
surveillance capitalism to
introduce you to a little bit
more about that. So because my
thesis uses a case study around
the College Board to demonstrate
what I'm calling an active
surveillance capitalism
impacting k 12. Students, I want
to take a moment to outline a
critical transition that
Shoshana Zuboff outlines in her
book on surveillance capitalism.
And so I want to explain what
she calls the behavioral value
reinvestment cycle, which is the
beginnings of surveillance
capitalism. So in this cycle,
this is a figure from her book
on the left, when information is
collected from individuals,
especially in an online setting,
it's rendered or turned into
data analyzed, and then use to
improve upon that surface for
that service for an individual.
So there's a certain amount of
data that's being rendered that
doesn't get used, and this is at
the top of the cycle. And
Shoshana Zuboff considers that
to be data exhaust or surplus
information, which is a
byproduct of this cycle. At some
point, companies realize that
that very small amount of data
exhaust, what we're now
characterizing his behavioral
surplus was actually enormously
profitable. So in the second
figure on the right, we see this
original cycle, the behavioral
value, reinvestment cycle,
actually on the bottom of this
much larger image, so it used to
be considered exhaust is now fed
into a much larger cycle. This
is not intended to benefit the
user at all this entirely is
intended to benefit a company.
So data previously rendered as
extra exhaust is fed into this
much larger system that can
predict our behavior as users.
And that can be extremely
profitable. So I think what's
important to recognize here is
while this does feed into
marketing, and advertising, as
we might expect, this cycle
really goes beyond that. So this
new marketplace here on the top
left of the figure, operates
around future behavior. So it's
probabilistic in nature, and
companies that make the best
predictions about people's
future behavior end up winning
in the end. So that way,
marketing and advertisement can
be used to shape people's
behavior based on predictions
and how people act. This is far
from the predictions of AI
taking over the world that many
have made. But it speaks to a
significant reduction in
individuals autonomy over their
actions. So what's the ultimate
outcome here, individuals lose
their autonomy over daily
decision making. And while
companies like Google have been
doing this for years, I argue
that we can and we should do our
best to minimize the impacts of
this on other aspects of
society, such as within our K
12, and higher education
systems. So now that we have a
better idea of the core tenets
and impacts of surveillance
capitalism, I want to pivot back
to the College Board, and share
some of the theoretical basis
for my research that has helped
me understand my own
relationship as a high schooler
with the College Board, and the
wider implications for the
College Board, student and
university facing services. So
in order to do so I built a
model of privacy based on the
work of two individuals, Helen
nissenbaum, and Arielle Waldman.
And I use this model of privacy
throughout my research to
analyze different aspects of
behavior from the College Board.
So here on the left, kind of
upper left is Ari Ezra Waldman's
privacy as trust. And this model
is one in which we recognize
that all of our relationships,
personal, professional, etc, are
built on trust. So we build a
sense of trust with individuals
or organizations to share any
kind of personal information,
just as we do with doctors or
with financial advisors. And in
those situations, those
individuals are legally required
to keep our information private.
So this is exactly what Waldman
calls privacy is trust, and it's
enforced legally nissenbaum on
the bottom right here, her model
of privacy as contextual
integrity is one under which the
distribution of data can happen
under two specific norms, and
you have to meet both of those
norms for distribution to be
okay. And those are called
appropriate appropriateness and
flow. So they help us ask
questions such as is the data
being collected in a certain
situation appropriate, and then
is the transfer of that data
from one party to another
appropriately. So just as an
example, it might be perfectly
appropriate for a grocery store
to collect information on the
types of food people buy in
order to restock the proper
amounts so that they always have
enough in stock, but it would be
less appropriate for that same
grocery store to ask patrons of
the store for a list of all of
the restaurants they like within
a one mile radius of their home.
Similarly, it might be
reasonable for that grocery
store to share the purpose the
purchasing habits of patrons
with their supplier for
restocking purposes. But it
wouldn't be appropriate flow or
distribution for that supplier
to then share that information
one step further with patrons
health insurance providers. So
here I have sort of my sketched
out model of privacy that I use
throughout my thesis. And I'm
arguing for a combined framework
of privacy in this trust and
privacy is contextual integrity.
So I'll start on the left in
terms of assumptions. So when we
analyze this instance of
surveillance capitalism within
the college process, we have to
assume in some sense that data
sharing will continue. So this
draws directly from weldments
work. Second, we have to assume
that students and their parents,
and even their teachers and
administrators are not always
aware of the data sharing that
happens, and how these data are
shared. And this is exactly what
happened to me as a student when
I was in high school. So next
are sorts of requirements for
data sharing of some sort, are
as follows exactly the norms of
appropriateness and flow as
defined by Nissenbaum. So we ask
again, are the data collected
appropriate to a specific
context? And then when
considering distribution or
flow? Is that distribution
appropriate? And how can
relationships of trust enable
and constrain distribution? So
finally, and this has been sort
of my biggest question
throughout all of this? How do
we actually do this? So I say
through two primary methods, and
the first is transparency, which
helps minimize any difference of
information between a data
provider and a data collector.
And the second and arguably most
important method is through
legal enforcement. And this
echoes Waldman's work as well.
So we need to build in legal
mechanisms that actually enforce
data privacy legislation, in
order to minimize potential harm
to students. So I want to
briefly highlight the different
methodologies I use in this
research just to show you a bit
of the varied approach that I
take. So I rely upon historical
research, in order to look at
the history of standardized
testing normalization of data
collection within our school
systems, policy analysis to
review all kinds of federal and
state laws surrounding student
data privacy, and then I dive
into primary research in order
to analyze documents that are
associated with the student
search service in the College
Board. And that even includes
some of my own documentation
from 10 years ago, and then
interviews to sort of situate
this work contextually within
the voices of individuals
connected to the college
admissions process. So college
enrollment consultants, college
counselors, admissions officers,
etc. So now that you have an
understanding of what I'm using
to analyze the actions of the
College Board, I'll bring you
back to my example of the
College Board student search
service to specifically look at
two examples of how the College
Board violates that framework of
privacy that I just built. So
one example relates the
inclusion of transparency in the
privacy framework. And the
second use is my own experience
participating in the student
search service as a high
schooler to illustrate a
violation of the norm of
distribution.
So as I mentioned before, the
student search service is the
college board's flagship program
to provide students with free
personalized college
recommendations. When a student
participates in a college board
exam like the SAT or PSAT, a
student can opt into this
service and provide all kinds of
information about themselves to
the College Board, such as their
address, their ethnicity,
gender, financial aid, need and
educational aspirations and
interests. The College Board
then takes this information,
plugs it into its proprietary
recommender systems, and then
provide students with
recommendations for college.
However,
to kind of pivot towards the
college facing service. The
College Board also collects this
information, and I'll quote here
to create the largest most
effective admissions search
database in the United States.
So that database it then markets
to universities and other
loosely educational
organizations through the
College Board search. And these
organizations and universities
have the option to lease student
names from the College Board in
a variety of ways. But at the
most basic level, it costs
colleges about 50 cents per name
to gain student information, as
written here on the bottom with
the college facing example. And
these are actual quotes that the
College Board uses to market
these two services whether it's
student facing or college
facing. The College Board is
very explicit about marketing
the College Board search as an
enrollment solution to help
universities market themselves
to students. And what I think is
most striking about this quote
on the bottom is specifically
this focus on marketing return
on investment. This is not
towards the university. These,
this is not intended to benefit
the students. So we know that
about 80% of students using the
College Board opt into the
student search service at some
time. And even if we approximate
this based on the number of
people taking the SAT in one
year, this is about 1.8 million
students. That's a big data set.
But research shows that the
student search service doesn't
really benefit students at all.
So according to an internal
called Word paper cited by the
Wall Street Journal in 2019, a
student whose information is
sold as part of the student
search service is about 0.1%
likelier to apply to a
university from which they've
received marketing materials of
some sort, and only about 0.2%
likely are to enroll in one of
those universities. So who
benefits from the students
search service, it's purely the
College Board and universities,
the College Board brings in
about 10 to 11% of the
organization's revenue every
year from the College Board
search and associated programs.
Universities gain access to
large quantities of data,
student information from
marketing and analytics,
individual students are barely
impacted, at least in a positive
way. So this, I argue, is
exactly what feeds into
surveillance capitalism. Large
amounts of data are collected
and distributed to third
parties. In this case,
universities and scholarship
organizations rendered at scale.
These data can be used to make
all kinds of predictions about
incoming students who will be
successful, who might drop out
who might major in what subject
who can pay and who can't.
So I want to take you through my
two small case studies to
illustrate some of the
challenges surrounding the
College Board student search
service and College Board
search. So this slide kind of
demonstrates the kinds of
information shared either
towards students or for parents
about the about the students
search service. So a student
considering signing up for the
students search service online,
is totaled, the college is paid
for the service. Online.
However, parents are not told
that colleges paid for their
children's information through
the students search service and
College Board search unless they
navigate to a separate web page
where they're told that
universities pay a license fee
to participate. This says
nothing about the explicit per
name basis of the service. So in
a test setting, on the other
hand, students are not told that
college is paid for their
information. And this is not in
the proctor script. So a proctor
administering the exam will
never say anything in the entire
exam that says that there's a
cost associated with the service
to universities, if and when
parents are provided with a
consent form for their children
to participate, which is not
required on the federal level,
but certain states or districts
might require. They're told the
same information as the FAQ
online, which is that
universities pay some kind of
license fee to participate. So
this difference in information
is very similar to what
economists call an information
asymmetry, and one that makes it
very difficult for individuals
to proceed within what we're
calling a relationship built on
trust between a student and the
College Board or parent and the
college worth. So the College
Board explicitly holds more
information about these programs
than students and parents who
are most responsible for
consenting to the service. So in
doing so, the College Board has
created a resellers market
between students and
universities, one which the
larger customer the university
will default as the most
important. The information
students are provided with in
different situations to
participate in this market is
quite minimal. But the lack of
transparency between the College
Board and students is missing.
What Shoshana Zuboff in her book
on surveillance capitalism
refers to as the shadow texts.
And that's this individual
invisible understanding of
what's really happening under
the surface. So the College
Board tells students that the
organization is helping them.
But the shadow text here tells a
very different story, that
students are helping
universities market themselves
and make predictions about their
incoming classes of students.
This is possible simply because
of the nature of a resellers
market, where the larger
customer is more likely to
benefit from then the smaller
customer and in this case, the
smaller customer isn't really a
customer at all, and is just the
supplier the students. So my
second example is around the
normal flow. And here's a brief
snippet of how the College Board
allows students to opt out of
the students search service. So
while the College Board claims
to lease student information,
I'm arguing that the
organization explicitly violates
the normal flow or distribution
outlined earlier by misinforming
students and parents about how
they disagree Have you
information. So as a reminder,
the normal flow circled here on
the bottom is one of two norms
described by Helen Nissenbaum.
Privacy is contextual integrity.
And this asks whether the actual
distribution of data from one
party to another the flow of
information, whether that's
appropriate.
So back to the College Board, a
student signs up for the
students search service, just as
I did as a high school and
likely many of my classmates
consenting to the distribution
of their data. The College Board
by claiming to lease Student
Information implies that such
data sharing is temporary. If a
student were to agree to such
distribution of their
information, then it would be
expected that after a student
revokes consent, ie opt out of
the program, that their student
data would be removed. However,
the College Board while claiming
to lease student data is
explicitly giving universities
data for a cost which is just
selling. So the College Board
will not redistribute student
data after student opts out. But
just as highlighted here, in
this FAQ on opting out program,
universities that already have
student information can continue
to use that information and
reach out to students. So to
provide a parallel situation,
which is especially funny given
that it's snowing outside for
many of us today. Imagine you
rent a car on vacation, says the
wishful thinking of the day,
you've signed a lease with a
rental agency. On the last day
of your lease, you're required
to return the car. If you keep
the car after your lease ends,
you're likely going to face
pretty large penalties as you
violated the terms of your
lease. So, with the College
Board, a student revoking
consent from the student search
service is the end of the lease.
If a university maintains access
to student information and
continues to use it, then by
definition, if that is within
the scope of allowance according
to the College Board, then the
College Board is very explicitly
selling rather than leasing
student information. And this
feeds directly into surveillance
capitalism. An individual signs
up for service thinking it will
provide one specific thing and
unknowingly becomes a part of a
completely different process. A
student can individually
unsubscribe from universities
email lists one at a time, which
in many cases could be in the
10s 50s hundreds of universities
reaching out, but that student
has absolutely no idea how that
university might continue to use
their information. And this
misdirection is a classic
component of surveillance
capitalism, students supply
their data for free into an
economy that ends up feeding off
of their data for a price. So
these types of data can then be
used in different forms of
marketing and analysis, not
unlike the emails that I
received from universities 10
years ago. And so all of this
marketing happens within a field
called enrollment management.
Enrollment Management as an
industry helps exists to help
colleges recruit and retain
students. So one educational
consultant I spoke with shared
with me that this extends to a
College's image or brand and
maintaining prestige and
publicity is very important for
colleges, both for nonprofit and
for profit universities. So at
many universities, this extends
beyond what we might think of as
students showing demonstrated
interest by attending an
information session or
participating in a campus visit.
This has even turned into
measuring student engagement
with the university through
clicks, marketing campaigns and
metrics. So there are many
companies that provide these
services to universities. And
some of them such as slate here
on the right, provide not only
marketing services, but also
what was described to me by an
admissions officer at a large
university as CRM services or
customer relationship
management. So here students or
customers for universities and
universities need to catch their
eye. But looking more
specifically at the quote I've
highlighted here on the right
above sleep. Many of these
companies provide all kinds of
analytical services through data
dashboards and other systems
that allow universities to make
predictions about student
outcomes and success. So this
form of prediction is exactly
what many scholars have warned
about taking personal
information in order to make
predictions about which students
will be successful graduate or
be able to pay. Many times this
even happens at schools
historically known for
discrimination. So this is what
Shoshana Zuboff refers to as
rendition of data into
prediction products and then
even further behavior
modification. Student
Information is used for
predictions that allow
universities to market
themselves to students and gain
customers through appealing to
students. It makes us ask the
question, Do students maintain
autonomy in this process and
what does this set students up
for in the future.
So in certain cases, the types
of marketing previously
mentioned can be helpful. And
they had that that type of
marketing has the ability to
bring in populations of students
otherwise marginalized from
higher education. But in many
cases, this marketing can be
extremely dangerous. So the
for-profit university industry
is a discriminatory and
predatory industry that preys on
students. These schools often
target students based on zip
codes for recruitment to figure
out which students might be
eligible for federal loads,
interviewees. I spoke with
shared of the focus on
recruiting military veterans as
well as veterans come with some
kind of educational funding from
the GI Bill. So these types of
universities use large amounts
of student data in order to
optimize their potential
incoming class for profit. And
programs, such as a student
search service, have the ability
to enable their actions. So
here's just a little bit of a
doodle of where student data
might go in this type of a
situation. So at the federal
level, students are not legal
stewards of their own data
within school systems until
they're 18. But exceptions are
made in many cases, when
organizations are deemed
educational in some sense.
organizations like the College
Board act as middlemen in these
processes, distributing highly
personal information to other
organizations and never asking
for the data back. So this third
level of organization or
university here, is now no
longer subject to the same level
of legal oversight of how data
is used. And this level acts
opaquely. And it's really
anyone's guess how information
might be used and further
distributed after it reaches
that level. So what we do know
is that student data is not used
only to recruit diverse
applicants. But in many cases,
it's also used within enrollment
management systems for predatory
lending practices for use in
predictive machine learning
models, and in targeted
advertisement. So organizations
such as the College Board, Mr. X
students to share personal
information, and enable the for
profit University and predatory
lending industries feeding into
surveillance capitalism
involving k 12 students.
So where do we go from here.
Unknown: So we know that
organizations like the College
Board are enabling this often
inappropriate distribution of
data that really does have the
impact the potential to impact
someone's life enormously. So I
argue for three primary action
items around this. So first, we
need to build some kind of
transparency of company data
policies, in order to clearly
communicate what companies hope
to do with student data. This
goes back to the way that
organizations like the College
Board describe their own
actions. When students and
parents see different
information when trying to learn
about services, where parents
are not provided with readable
consent forms or data policies.
When a student takes something
like the sap within school,
there's an information asymmetry
created, that makes it quite
impossible for individuals to
make educated decisions about
how to act and whether to sort
of enter this relationship with
an organization. So the College
Board has created a resellers
market through the student
search service, and it provides
great benefit to itself and to
university customers, while
providing little to students in
the process. Second, there needs
to be greater oversight of
organizations collecting student
data and enforcement of laws,
and legally binding agreements
such as something called the
student privacy pledge, which is
a pledge that lots of
educational organizations and
companies have signed, including
the College Board that says that
they don't sell student data.
And when an organization signs
this type of a pledge, it is
actually legally enforceable
through the FTC. But we've seen
very minimal enforcement if, if
any of these types of pledges
already. So third, I argue that
we need greater privacy
protections for students. And
this really extends to consumer
data privacy as well. This is
something individuals and
companies agree with individuals
feel better protected, knowing
that individual information is
protected. And companies would
prefer to comply with federal
laws rather than the fractured
landscape of individual state
privacy laws. So these takeaways
are by no means exhaustive, but
they feed into a greater area of
consumer data privacy and lots
of individuals and activists
fighting to protect consumers
data more broadly. So I hope
that I've convinced you that
programs such as the College
Board students search service
are unethical and feed into
surveillance Capitalism
surrounding our K 12 students by
creating this opportunity for
student information to be
rendered into predictive
products, helping universities
make predictions about student
success to inform their
marketing. We need to regulate
these programs and others in
order to make sure children and
parents understand how their
information is being used. The
College Board over time has
become ingrained as this odd not
for profit acting as a
gatekeeper to higher education
within our K 12 and higher
education areas. And my hope is
that by fighting back against
surveillance capitalism within
our educational spaces, we can
ensure more equitable access to
higher education for students
and minimize the impact of
predatory practices within the
college application process.
Roya Moussapour: Thank you.
Vivek Bald: All right, thank
you, really, we have a little
bit of time for questions. And
so for those of you who are on
screen, if you can use your your
hands, you're either virtual or
actual hands. I will try to keep
track of the order that they're
coming in. So first, William?
William Uricchio: Well, thanks.
That was that was terrific. It's
terrific. It's important. It's
logical, and it's ethical. And
the legal system, I'm afraid is
neither of those you've made a
compelling case logically and
and ethically. The student
privacy pledges is an
interesting example. If there is
indeed violation here, there's a
class action suit waiting to
happen. And this is a relatively
well endowed organization. Why
hasn't that happened? Has it
happened? What's the legal
advice on this word? Because I'm
sure there's some apps and
mighty powerful loopholes that
are blocking this.
Roya Moussapour: And that I
think it is exactly those those
powerful loopholes that have
been the problem. So there have
been a couple of cases that have
actually been tossed out where
people have said, you know, the
College Board has sold my
information, and I would like to
sue them because of this.
There's there's a class action
right now, that's being argued,
I think it was filed last
spring, that we don't know about
yet. But the the actual issue,
and this is I think the most
challenging thing about doing
this type of work has been that
no one has been able to
demonstrate in the legal court,
actual harm from this very
directly, because there's no
direct kind of tracking that's
possible from an individual
student into some kind of
colleges system into some kind
of marketing or, you know, a for
profit universities, predatory
lending practices. So courts
have thrown these issues out
purely on the technicality of
demonstrated harm. And this has
been an you could ask Justin
this question as well. And he
and I have gone back and forth
on this many times, in terms of
how do you sort of beat one of
these issues before you see the
implications happen. And we've
seen the implications of for
profit colleges. And we know
that they target students based
on where they are. And we know
that zip code has a really high
correlation with race. And so it
ends up impacting people of
color most directly. But it's
almost like there needs to be
some massive investigative
journalism project that that is
able to actually get someone to
say from point A to point B,
yes, we have this direct link,
because we have people who were
saying we need better
protections for students. And we
have people saying we have this
enormous industry of predatory
lending. But the actual
connection, at least in a court
has not yet been made, as what I
would say, and it's something I
think about, and I'm thinking
about as I'm doing all of my
revisions now as well. Thank
you.
Vivek Bald: I think Andrew is
next and then to
Andrew Whitacre: Thanks, Vivek.
So I just want to make sure I
understood one thing that you
said that there is no benefit
basically to schools in terms of
application rates and yield on
this data sets. I got
Roya Moussapour: no that that
hasn't that. So it has.
Andrew Whitacre: Yeah. I wanted
to understand that, point 01
point 02.
Roya Moussapour: Yeah, yeah,
this is a great thing to
clarify. So for an individual
student, there's very little
impact. But for universities, it
has a huge impact, because you
basically can scale up while it
might for an individual student
have a really minimal impact on
what ends up happening in terms
of their application. When
schools are buying hundreds of
1000s of names, all of a sudden
a very little impact for one
student over that 100,000
200,000 or more number of names
does scale up. So it is this is
a there's actually a Chapter in
Kathy O'Neill's weapons of mass
destruction that discusses this
exactly from the perspective of
yield and of the number of
applicants to university. And I
think this all sort of started
in the 70s and 80s, when US News
and World Report started
reporting, college rankings, and
this sort of directly fed into
that at the very edge
of that interest. And then real
quick second question, what's
the history of selling data?
Because I know the college
board's been around since early
1900s, I think it was set up as
a way to basically create the
sap to standardized testing for
admissions offices. But there
must have been a presentation
that somebody gave at some point
saying, oh, I've got this great
idea. We should. Yeah,
this started in 1972. Under I
think it was called the student
data questionnaire at the time,
it was a little bit different.
But what's really interesting to
track sort of in the history of
this is that while the College
Board has been at least somewhat
consistent about, you know,
leasing student data, media
reporting on this service has
always used the word self. There
has been never, there's never
been a point where someone had
said, Yeah, they're leasing
student data. We totally agree
with that. But it has always
been since the absolute very
beginning. It's been the College
Board, selling student data,
selling student data over and
over again.
Andrew Whitacre: Right, thanks.
Vivek Bald: I think TL was next,
if TL still has a question.
T.L. Taylor: Well, I guess,
maybe I'll just I don't hope you
can hear me. Okay. That was
really interesting presentation.
And I love the kind of close
read and analysis of the system
and how the data is flowing. I
guess my question might have
actually been slightly answered
and piggybacking on Andrew's
because I felt like there was a
implied model of, of huma
agency running through the talk
At the same time, what I fel
was some some undermining of th
actual efficacy of th
predictive system. And I thin
this is one of the interestin
critiques that's emerging i
it's a little bit sometimes
hype and a promise of predictio
that doesn't actually pay off.
think this is one of the thing
we're seeing around the critiqu
critiques of predictiv
policing, where actually
there's lots of ways you ca
poke holes in the kind of impac
and efficacy of those systems
So I don't know if I have a wa
to ask this quite right. I mean
you might have addressed it wit
the injuries, if you if you hav
a sense of where my question an
critique was heading, I'd be I'
be happy to hear more thoughts
But you know, I do I do wonde
sometimes these systems a littl
bit, promise more than the
actually can pay off. So anyway
I'll just I'll leave it at that
Yeah. S
Roya Moussapour: I think what,
what sort of strikes me about
this, in terms of where the
predictive models in a sense are
coming in, is that they're
happening, it's sort of all
different levels. The College
Board has their own system, the
College Board ends up
maintaining all of this
information. And they have an
entire research organization
within the organization itself,
that does all kinds of analysis
with this data. But I think
what's what's challenging is,
every single university that has
data in this regard, is using it
in a totally different way and
has a totally different system.
One of the universities that I
spoke with, I spoke with a
researcher, who said, you know,
we know for us that student
success correlates really,
really strongly with SAT
cores. While you know, other
niversities, you know, I went
o Boden Boden said there a very
ong time ago, we're no longer
oing to require test scores,
ecause we don't think that they
eally have an impact. And at
oth of those universities, you
ave highly successful students,
ighly intelligent students. And
n one system, they've decided
hat their predictions are that
he SAT scores really matter. A
d in others, they decided that i
doesn't really matter at all. S
it's, I don't know if this e
tirely answers your question, b
t it's it's very fractured. A
d I think sort of I noticed in t
e chat, Justin has been doing a
great job of moderating, m
derating the chat for me. T
ank you, Justin. But one of my c
lleagues at TSL, at the lab, a
ked, you know, should we just b
calling for the abolishment o
the College Board? And t
ere's sort of two different w
ys that this could happen. I p
rsonally, you know, we've seen o
er the last year how many s
hools are just totally fine w
thout asking for for SAT sc
res. And this year has really be
n a reckoning for that. I th
nk MIT just announced the ot
er day that they're not going to
be asking for SAT scores aga
n. So it is this odd time of bei
g able to say maybe we sho
ld just start getting rid of thi
organization, but even the
, there plenty of other pla
es that have gotten in tro
ble before that have been col
ecting student data and oth
r ways that have gotten you kno
, they've they've run into iss
es legally surveying stu
ents for personal inf
rmation, and they're still sel
ing data to universities. So so
t's sort of the models are all
spread out, but the data is com
ng in from very, very many pla
es that are sort of doing it und
r the books.
T.L. Taylor: Can I just say I
appreciate that answer. And I
think it points to part of what
I'm, I'm trying to think through
is, you know, there's a long
history of the sociology of
education and educators
themselves critiquing systems.
what I'm wondering is if the
theoretical models that come
with something like Zuboff
surveillance, capitalism are a
perhaps a more, a bigger and a
kind of unwieldy more of an
unwieldy hammer than we actually
need to make the critiques we
want to make because there are
really interesting theories of
agency packaged in and I, you
know, I love Zuboff, especially
her first book, but I mean, so
anyway, so thank you for that
answer, because it begins to get
at some of what I think I was a
little bit sloppily pointing to.
Vivek Bald: Alright, Eric, and
then we will be moving on to our
next presentation.
Eric Klopfer: My question
actually builds on the stuff you
just talked about there at the
end, which was the past year?
Yeah, there's been a lot of
disruption. Yeah, that most
schools haven't required any
standardized exams over the last
year. And there's some data
starting to emerge on that in
terms of what it's done for
diversity. And, and you know,
that it's a little bit hard to
tease out exactly, because
there's also, you know, pandemic
impacts on that as well, in
terms of who's applied to where,
but it's really, how do you how
did you know that it's been a
massive experiment, you sort of
see that as a disruption to the
entire system? Or is it going to
sort of settle back down to
equilibrium?
Roya Moussapour: I would love to
see it as a disruption to the
system. I don't think we're far
enough out yet to see how it
might impact. I've, I've traced
a little bit not in the scope of
this work, but just in my own
reading, trying to follow what's
happening this year. And I read
an article a few weeks ago that
specifically talked about how,
you know, we've seen application
numbers jump enormously at all
these sort of elite universities
that are not requiring test
scores. But what we've also seen
is his numbers dropped terribly
at community colleges, and all
kinds of sort of other less non
the non four year universities,
which I think are still
extremely important parts of our
educational system, and trade
schools and such. So I think it
is sort of a reckoning point.
And we're, we're not yet far
enough to see how it goes. But I
would be really saddened to see,
oh, well, now that we don't have
SAT scores, let's say
ypothetically, we have everyone
pplying for this set of
chools, they all get that much
ore competitive. And then we
ee all these universities,
hich are catering to non
raditional students, which are
atering to sort of students who
eed an A, we're going to jump
rom an associate's to a four
ear in the way that I think
ike the UC system has done
eally well over the years. I
ould be really sad to see those
ort of windell because of all
f a sudden this focus on elite
chools without test scores, so
t really could go either way.
Vivek Bald: Right. Thank you so
much, Roya.
Roya Moussapour: Thank you.